[Music]
Adventurer I need your help have you
heard the news apparently other
adventurers were duplicating items to
sell in the next realm over to stop the
economy from being completely ruined the
mayor has shut off all methods for
making money
I guess they weren't using a consistent
database to protect against exploits so
I need you to venture ahead and tell
them about Cloud spanner
Adventure as you surely know Cloud
spanner is a relational database that
enforces strong consistency for
transactions and easily scales depending
on workload
spanner also allows Global applications
to interact with the data using
multi-regional configurations
zero downtime maintenance and online
schema changes with industry-leading
availability guarantees just add to the
benefits of spanner
these reasons make spanner a great
choice to ensure consistency for
critical interactions such as buying and
selling items between players in
multiplayer games er I mean adventurers
in other realms
oh you didn't know about spanner
okay here to help you get familiar with
spanner I have built a simulator that
manages player profiles to track Games 1
versus played statistics as well as the
ability to buy and sell on the trading
post please try it out
this simulator is written in go and
consists of four back-end rest API
microservices
the profile service handles player
registration
then the matchmaking service allows
those players to be assigned to game
simulations
when simulations are closed out one
winner is chosen and each player has its
stats updated for a number of games
played and if they won number of games
won
the item service allows players to
acquire items and money as game
simulations are being played and finally
the Trade Post Service allows players to
list items for sale for other players to
buy
this simulator leverages Locust a python
framework to generate workload to the
services
with a few commands you can easily start
signing up players and having them play
games and ultimately buy and sell items
from here it's easy to test how well
spanner holds up to the demand
as more players sign up more game
simulations can be created and more
items can be traded
when it comes time spanner can scale up
without impacting players to allow even
more capacity
so if you are building a multiplayer
game that demands High concurrency for a
distributed player base spanner is the
perfect foundation for success as you
embark on your journey to help prepare
you I am sharing two code Labs that go
over the simulator in depth these will
allow you to get Hands-On with an actual
application using Cloud spanner
when you are done you will be equipped
to fight back against exploits that ruin
game economies
at any time if you have any questions
please leave them in the comments Below
Good Luck Adventure
thank you